ich habe ziemlich genau einer woche
video hochgeladen dem ich darauf
eingegangen bin dass dsds ein video von
mir geklaut hat und wie kann ich das
vielleicht dass ein gros fernsehsender
einfach so nach einblendung aus einem
video in dem ich vor komme nimmt und in
die sendung ein packte scheinbar das
ultra viele von euch interessiert und
deswegen kommt heute nachfolge video
dazu mit dem ich darauf eingehen werde
wie ich weiter mit der sache umgehen
werde ob ich dir jetzt erst mal klagen
werde und auch eure fragen zu dem thema
beantworten werde erster kommentar kommt
von ribana haupt die schreibt dass rtl
ist auch schon clips auf youtube videos
nehmen muss echt arm und ja genau mein
gedanke ich würde gar nicht so weit
gehen zu sagen dass rtl ist jetzt
brauchen interessant zu bleiben aber wie
überlegt mal irgendein youtube auf
dieser plattform hat ein video einfach
wo unter wasser irgendwie eher sinkt wie
kommen dass in so eine fernsehsendung
ein dass sowas wird in youtuber machen
also youtuber würde sagen okay welche
einblenden kann ich neben was das witzig
aber ein fernsehsender die haben
wahrscheinlich 300 leute die pro folge
arbeiten schon seit andere dann ja aber
den nächsten kommentar habe ich mich
besonders gefreut titel gelesen hätte
drauf gedrückt seppel im fernsehen
weggedrückt leuten verständlich ok wird
weiter mit den korrekturen der nächste
kommentar ist auch natürlich super hat
eine sehr gute frage zu dem thema
gestellt und es einfach gut weiter
gehend mitgedacht und hat gesagt dsds
gift und dann jetzt die frage ich würde
gar nicht weiter aufschieben
die meisten von euch interessiert hat
glaube ich und da kann ich wissen was zu
erzählen die frage lautet kannst du rtl
jetzt verklagen das war im allgemeinen
wahrscheinlich ja ich kann bestimmt da
jetzt klagen oder wahrscheinlich max er
weil es einen ausschluss zu einem video
war und ich muss dazu sagen es ist nicht
das erste mal dass mir das passiert ist
ich hatte schon mal ein video gemacht so
wie damals und bio actives hommes und
rtl hat den beitrag gemacht haben die
reaktion von ihm angezeigten da drin
aber eben auch ich und habe ich auch
keine zustimmung zu geben sondern auch
einfach verwendet
aber leute in deutschland gibt es ein
großer unterschied zwischen zwei dingen
wo man eigentlich sagen würde diesen das
gleiche und zwar einerseits recht haben
und recht bekommen und in dem fall ist
es nicht mal 1000 prozentig glaube ich
recht habe ich war ein marxist video und
maxi ist mein bruder auch ein youtube
von dem modell das video geklaut der
verklagt jetzt verklagt weil mein
gesicht zu sehen ist verklagten max
heißt auch sein video war dann die
nächste frage heute der ausschuss war
jetzt auch keine stunde lang das waren
23 sekunden die frage ist was sagt dann
riecht ja ich denke wirklich ernsthaft
drüber nach leute ich denke erst mit
gerade drüber nach was würde passieren
wenn man ihn verklagen würde und selbst
wenn eindeutig klar ist dass man recht
hat ist es immer noch nicht gesagt dass
man auch recht bekommt das heißt dass
auch ein richter sagt okay du hast recht
ich stehe jetzt ein schadensersatz kraft
aber so ist es in deutschland zwei
verschiedene paar schuhe und dazu muss
ich sagen das hat sich seit damals schon
diesen fällen mit rtl das war glaube ich
rtl exclusiv oder sowohl mein material
verwendet wurde und da habe ich auch ein
anwalt gefragt abgefragt was meinst du
sollte ich rtl verklagen falls ich
verklage was bringt mir das aber noch
ein paar hintergrundinfos zu geben das
können durchaus schon einige tausend
euro sein
je nach fall also das kann durchaus
schon passieren und jetzt wahrscheinlich
einige von euch sagen egal ich trag
zeitung aus fünf euro die stunde und du
denkst drüber nach ob du verklagt
sondern dabei tausende von euro bekommen
könnte sagte es ja ich denke darüber
nach weil es eben auch schweineteuer ist
ein anwalt zu beauftragen der sich dafür
einsetzt und selbst dann ist eben nicht
sicher ist dass man die sache auch
wirklich gewinnt oder man pech hat
schreibt man auf den anwaltskosten
sitzen hat der anwalt keine ahnung 1500
2000 euro verdient man kriegt gar nix
dann geben wir direkt zum nächsten super
durchdachten kommentar
es geht die goldene dvd auf seinen
nacken und dann habt ihr noch 1
kommentar was ich nicht verstehe ist
dass es dir nicht passt dass man einen
ausschnitt von deinem verwendet wo du
drin zu sehen bist aber dass gleichem
maße dem du einen ausschnitt von dsds
zeigt so kevin schlecht singt und dieter
und so weiter zu sehen sind damit hast
du eigentlich erst recht kann nicht
verstehen dass du dem ersten mal
bestimmt vorsätzen haus also einerseits
sage ich wirklich das dürfe nicht bei
mir machen aber ich mag es bei denen
oder
es gibt aber einen fall in dem man
materialien von anderen verwenden da und
das so genannte zitat ganz kurz erklärt
wie das funktioniert man behauptet in
dem video beispiel eine sache sagt zum
beispiel der himmel ist blau und dann
kann man beispielsweise ein video von
simon angenehm wurde den himmel filmt
und das quasi als beweis dafür nehmen
dass der sinn von zitat man behauptet
irgendwas und fügt das dann als belegen
und ich glaube dass so ein bisschen das
was ich in meinem video gemacht habe
also der titel sagt das ja allein schon
der ist erst mal ein video geklaut und
dann benutze ich in einem video auch nur
die ausschnitte die relevant sind um
diese behauptung eben zu belegen auf der
anderen seite sagt dieter bohlen bei der
ist der ist okay du singst wieder
teichpumpe dann kommt die anwendung von
und das würde ich sagen ist also nichts
was in dem seine erlaubt ist hätte aber
zum beispiel gesagt wisst ihr was unter
wasser zu singen hört sich über das
scheiße an und hätte damals video
eingeblendeten härtesten zitat sein
können weil er quasi damit dass unter
wasser singen sich scheiße an beweist
aber leute man muss auch ehrlich sein so
unter youtube an er ist das eigentlich
schon üblich dass man auch mal eine
einbindung von dem nimmt immer irgendwie
lustigen gesichtsausdruck von dem so
dass es endlich auch mal und da würde
ich auch nicht aufregen sollte jetzt
unsympathisch zum beispiel eine
anwendung für mich beendet und lustig
macht ist okay und dann ist da ja nicht
sein video weil er ist quasi eine person
er macht das so sehen die professionell
ist einfach alleine dabei ich bin auch
alleine so ich verstehe dass wie das bei
ihm ist wenn so ein fernsehsender macht
das ist ein team von janka nach 50 bis
300 leuten die so eine sendung machen da
könnte man eigentlich schon mehr
erwarten das was von diesem kurzen video
leute fragen ich bin wieder da noch ein
bisschen klein deswegen hatte ich kurz
heute bis zum nächsten mal machte